[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté aujourd'hui vous les aurez préparé
je crois détails des cayes que nous
allons farci au foie gras et aux
réserves face à cet emprunt tout à fait
traditionnelle chez vous bien sûr nous
en a partout vous ça arrive c'est
l'entrée nous un peu comment ils sont à
l'heure si belle qui est bien c'est une
très jolie petites écailles
c'est plus gros que la grive un peu
encore fait que plume et qu'est ce qu'il
vous faut les faire et bien pas grand
chose tiens on peut dire il nous faut un
bon vin sucré
il ne faut de l'armagnac des selleries
ça c'est pour les légumes de l'oignon de
l'ail du raisin du foie gras bien sûr
après la crème fraîche sel et poivre et
c'est toujours pareil il ya problème
pour les plus mais là elles sont toutes
belles mais pour les plumes et vous avez
vous même quand vous faites vous dirais
la plume et c'est tout et bien sûr on
l'aimé on prend les ailes ont les mêmes
panneaux venir et puis ça se plaint de
tout ce n'est tout seul on met pas de
briller en europe le congrès et surpris
mais c'est assez bien sûr vous les avez
vidé insu oui bien sûr elles sont prêtes
quant à l'emploi on commence n'a été par
les rides bien alors que fait-on avec
ces raisons et bien on va prendre un
gros raisin il faut l'épauler il faut
cette sorte de raison d'être et oui il
faut l'épauler alors là je vais faire
attention on a l'avantagé trouvé très
tard dans l'année
oui et aussi et en plus on perd alors
s'il ya une personne qui les ont
précédés et ce n'a pas de perception
fait tout bonnement avait le couteau
pointu le mec la pince à épiler ont fait
un plus gros trou comme et puis on
n'abîme pas le raisin et a pu enlever à
mariner dans la marianne et voilà alors
en faire un second tour et évidemment on
a préparé qu'elle avance parce que ça ce
serait beaucoup de ce seul plan tous
alors on va rajouter un autre il ya
combien de pépin à peu près de 3 après
un travail minutieux sans bien entendu
on les trouve en boîte mais c'est
beaucoup moins bon mais bien sûr parce
que là c'est nature s'éveille son fruit
sans accord les mares eux ils sont
toujours punis après exactement
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous allez bien de la manière oui on va
les mettre à mariner dans de l'armagnac
que je vous donne la vente et merci
alors voilà toujours le même un petit
soupçon et en principe il faut les
laisser mariner combien euros il faut
les laisser mariner bien qui sait mieux
bien
deux heures trois heures ça départ il
faudra que oui pendant que les réserves
marines qu'est ce qu'on fait est
l'invité et bien on va s'occuper de
l'autre foie gras alors on le pose sur
la relance
si je comprends bien voilà or nos
copains on coupe une bonne lichette de
fois voilà on leur fera en deux il faut
faire de jolis petits carrés bien joli
mais c'est pas des petits carrés se sont
déjà d'assez jolie le gars est carré
voile a été qu'est ce que c'est les airs
de fait de verser le fiel ça gèle ou
parent ne soit pas de gêner mais je vais
l'enlever jupe t1 gentiment dès que j'en
aurai besoin n'a pas grave non c'est pas
grave alors ensuite la caille
enfin d'autres petites cailles douce et
nous opposerions bien voilà alors en lui
écarte bien autour de bâle
on y met deux grains de raisin il faut
pas avoir peur de prendre l'armagnac est
quand même au derrière on met notre
petit carré de foie gras un joli les
bouchures derrière niang reprend deux
autres graines là et puis c'est dire
combien la contiennent voilà hombourg
complètement non complètement et après
dans le coup on le couple que tout ça ne
sonne ipad 1 800 parce qu'on va le faire
cuire en cocotte quand on ne fait cuire
et dans un plat est au four et bien on
fait tout bonnement ça et comme ça
tienne debout ça tient mais en cocotte
il faut la tourner alors on lui bouche
verrière alors quel est l'avantagé ou
l'inconvénient de cuir en cocotte plutôt
confirmé vous savez qu'un concorde c'est
délicieux tous qui cuit en cocotte ça
fait son petit jus davantage au four
wheel et on peut régler comme on veut ah
oui et celui-là fusil au four est ce que
vous mettriez une barde
non non c'est ballon parce que ce serait
tout paris shot
oui et non il faut surveiller le cuire
doucement mais pas de barbe
pas de bar si vous en prenez deux à la
fois oui ça va encore plus ça va plus
voilà la lte le trou de balle est cousue
oui elle est prête à renom qu'est-ce
qu'il faut laisser responsable on promet
bien sûr on a ça les ans la poivre bien
rire même pas ce prix là c'est une
viande qu'il a pas tellement de boue
alors la région arctique vous tapotez
toujours un peu pour que ça amènerait
pour faire pénétrer
voilà les propos leur notre cahier qui
est prête à cuire
on va la mettre et on va faire bien
entendu d'autres là mêmes opérations on
l'apprend on lui ouvre bien derrière et
pure mais les grains de raisin sellal et
bien bouché jeunes dans une autre la
comprendre deux frères notre morceau de
foie est bien joli trou il ya ni hao et
rue plus parce que ça accueilli parce
que ça q vitesse 1 et des grains de
raisin c'est la l1 contiennent 3 aussi
mais ça va être délicieux vous entendez
le signal du lukmanier la manivelle à
magnac un petit bruit sympathique et à
belize et au cou et toujours pareil
et après on va placer d'un autre cocotte
sur notre gars étaient cuits oui très
vite qu'il faut pas faire ça vous allez
nous montrer ça dans un an vous attend
bien sûr donc ils sont prêtes
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et bien on va
les mettre à cuire maintenant tout de
suite alors on va les mettre dans notre
cocotte vous avez victoire de la grèce
mme kanaté grèce
voilà on va les faire dorer
de chaque côté
elles sont maintenant bien doré d'envoi
défendu de faire fuir
bref si on va bien clan b l'amputer
cagnes
las
ça on peut dire quel plan viable bien
maintenant il ya pas de ces eaux
on va les couvrir
et laisser mijoter combien le service
ajouté un quart d'heure un cap
maintenant on va s'occuper de la purée
de céleri et comment la fête vous la
purée de céleri et bien c'est très
facile on va tout de suite coupé le pied
de céleri à céleri rave
c'est rare qu'on appelait ça va être
bien sûr non bien sûr
alors vous le coupez comme ça on ne
reçoit pas trop trop gros et on le coupe
en quatre
oui et on le met dans notre eau
bouillante qui a été salie et pourquoi
avez vous préparé des faunes et ont
mélangé il faut toujours mettre un peu
de temps de merde à peu rétablie de
pommes de terre
salut mes moyens consistants on va les
laisser un tiers pour la bonne raison
que c'est un peu plus lourd à cuire les
scénarii que les pommes de terre
alors on va mettre la porno terre
entière et tous à bakou le cuir et tout
ça rassure c'est le oui mais sa cuisse
invités quand même et ça qu assez vite
quand même on regarde et maintenant on
va regarder nos kayes
alors où sont elles n'ont qu'à y
s'appellerait journée la très jolie
alors que va-t-on faire
il y aura de sortir on va les sortir je
vous donne un plan peut-être pour lui
même et je voulais bien voilà on va les
sortir et on va finir mal sont bien
dorés un objet de cette préparation de
jus est très joli et ben oui avec tout
ce qu'on a mis dix ans oui ça n'est pas
très étonnant alors qu'est ce que vous
allez rajouter mais maintenant on va
rajouter les réserves des raisins qui
trempe dans l'armagnac
depuis plusieurs heures déjà je me
trompe et la cuite ring en mangeant
locale
on met nos réserves a dedans oui et
couru lors c'est tout non on les remet
eu un petit peu oui là et on va mettre
notre sauternes
si on va baisser mais vu que les gars là
ça va avec donc et on va mettre notre
sauternes et on va laisser mijoter 10
minutes à couvert ou découvert couvert à
couvert à ouidah un petit soupçon aussi
il ya du cern et tout ça va me jeter à
peu près combien de temps y minutes
laisser mijoter on va laisser réduire un
petit peu des nues quand va laisser un
petit peu d'air à la cocotte céleri et
pommes de terre ou la date bien cuit oui
vous allez passer à la mouline à la
moulinette comme on l'a toujours fait
dans les scènes exactement ça va très
vite et vous les croisez un peu à la
cuillère ou bon ça va passer buts e
marche arrière ça y est voilà est
d'assez bon là et ensuite eh bien on
souhaiterait finir ma purée on va mettre
notre lait chaud l'autre beurre puis un
petit peu de poivre
oui on va finir carrément non un peu
peur et voulant remettre dans la
casserole alors pour la finir pour
l'association lancé chez mercer quand il
a fini pratiquement là le beurre du
poivre notre lait qu'on a fait chauffer
je voulais tourner un peu pour la
connaissez pas trop là qu'elle soit bien
là on revient à tourner mais y avoir
comme la sécher un peu je crois sur le
cela parce que son savait trop liquide
non vous l'apprenez la voilà la haine
notre excellente on va la remettre sur
le feu dans une autre casserole pareille
jours l'armée
oui
et puis ça y est et on va regarder aux
cayes
on va engager une autre jeu où il en est
et où il en est oui ah bin là il est
très bien il a bien réduit ses jolies à
te dire oui maintenant on va réchauffer
le coeur très bien on va les replonger
dans notre sauce qui est réduit à bon
quart d'heure un bon quart d'heure est
devenu à celje oui non oui bien plus
appétissantes et puis on va nous
ressortir en suivant et en mauve a juste
un petit instant les réchauffer pour
faire soit bien chaude
oui voilà et on va les ressortir pour
les limites louis pour les finir avec du
jus ne veut sa team vient de sonder
réchauffer et des raisins et des raisins
tôt
fallait pas qu'elle recuit il va
l'évaluer l'océan en occupe exactement
et on va faire notre finition avec notre
fameux cocu rome alors ça c'est ce
instruments des landes que vous avez
fait faire exprès exactement qui est
très traditionnelle exactement qu'on
trouve pas dans les magasins et que nous
allons utiliser maintenant pour les
films prévient donc concurrents et comme
il faut c'est à dire qu'il a rougi la
rougir sur la braise les brûlant on va
finir l'opéra c'est qu'est ce que vous
allez faire avec ce qu'on est bien on va
mettre notre nar oui au jambon nous
allons bien enfoncer les deux morceaux
voici
il fonde alors au contre l'avis de du
cocuron donc et flandre m'anime sommes
hélas est excellent car c'est le graal
jambon qui va devenir de grands les
petits bouts supplémentaires
on va en mettre un tout petit peu sur la
purée aussi profiter ça ne va pas gâcher
ce concurrent qu'on trouve pas dans le
commerce que tel un empereur en
traditionnel que vous avez gardé
longtemps avec nous mêmes voilà donc ça
se vend pas il faut les faire alors à
part le cocu rond et bien si vous avez
envie d'essayer de serre comme nous et
quand anomalies t on continue on
continue
[Musique]